is that it is important to stay
without water will not stay in the ditty and
when there was no bar had talal fish
and now I think I've been told
Talk about shy love three I left
many goals and mark a
every day today she lives like this too.
It paints to stay beautiful belmonte
there is another problem also of the rai already
unthinking machão could magaia the boss
is formed and announces that he thought I
wherever it is guaranteed that
ball but knows our fan the whole mother
world here
nor do you feel that many years ago you
so feel the happy merry with that
air inspires you when you're already
big and you feel something like this
different knows that culture of agony
who pushes the wind gacc one thing
You got it.
It's very strange there
I think it's because of the sea
treatment and no more machine is over
and protects the woman from taking
woman makes food for the woman who is already a father
of banana foreign currency cassava
Renais leaves the woman who has been
Do not make me the man already hunts and
have to pick up and say no
Go get it or you will not take cassava.
on the rock there is no potato search in the
wants to do nothing democratic and the
neighbor is already blessed with benê
understood I do not like
It says there that the white woman does not
toenail is she thought it best I've seen
white white woman speaks so the
fed a lot and has is in chat michigan is that
made of the old
that's when we get a white
in our vein that it was kind of like this
understood not we feel xikrin rooms
Brazil, my mombaka grandma already
Most fashion design number that went
show on the portal support okay that
I never took care of the time, I got there.
There nobody daniel I arrived I wonder
priest speak to me that it is
The dam was not even explained to you anything.
anything
the emha woman marilya speaks thus to
Trust me and nobody explains anything to us.
what does this means
Nobody in pa there, I'll come, man.
full of joão minaz all ne
I told him you do not have shame.
There I was explaining how to stay very
cheerful with me and you're the only person
who arrives here explains things to
What we meant, this scares the
This is scary because the bank does not
left in the woods even outside of himself
the big river is to speak as soon as the river
win the river bar that goes ivory
I go to the cashier there but I already saw it and rudi can
here with fear document that will destroy
all we get is that fish what a date
I came to us
the bank will get hold of us though
bacajá border and when we got used to it
with the white bank in history and everything
however, it only
We think we can communicate on it tomorrow, we can
see in others